patinoire hier hôpital aujourd'hui
moscou essayé de faire face à la flambée
des contaminations dues coville 19 en
déployant de nouveaux lits
malheureusement la situation devient de
plus en plus tendu à cause de la
propagation d'une variante delta du
virus jugé plus agressifs et plus
mortelle le faible nombre des personnes
vaccinées dans la capitale n'aide pas
non plus cet hôpital mobile de 1300 lits
ouverts dans l'arène clac couillet est
actuellement remplis à 80 %
le service de réanimation est plein la
hausse du nombre de malades a commencé
en mai et ne cesse de se poursuivre
selon les médecins 80 % des personnes
hospitalisées sont atteints du variant
delta du coronavirus maintenant nous
voyons qu'il y ait cette nouvelle souche
nous voyons le déroulement de la maladie
je peux vous le dire qu'il y a beaucoup
de jeunes patients ce qui s'explique à
mon avis par le non respect des règles
d'hygiène publique
le virus n'a pas disparu il est
nécessaire de faire preuve de beaucoup
de vigilance et de précaution est donc
sage ligne malheureusement cela s'est
produit parce qu'on a cessé d'observer
les règles où on a commencé à négliger
les règles qu'on utilisait largement par
le passé les règles de son très simple
il s'agit du port du masque de la
distanciation sociale la désinfection
des mains et bien évidemment il ne faut
pas participer à de grands
rassemblements de masse qui réunissent
beaucoup de monde nous dire plus de
vingt mille nouveaux cas de coronavirus
ont été détectés en russie ces dernières
24 heures dans presque 8000 à mouscou
les autorités sanitaires tire la
sonnette d'alarmé et appelle la
population à respecter les gestes
barrières et à se faire vacciner
situation épidémiologique dans les pays
restent difficiles aujourd'hui dans un
certain nombre de régions elle est très
grave depuis la semaine écoulée
l'augmentation du nombre des cas dans le
pays
en comparaison avec la situation d'il ya
quatre semaines est de 100%
ils ont doublé à présent il ya une
dynamique de croissance dans presque
toutes les régions et avec une intensité
diverses comme cela a déjà été dit quant
à la structure d'âge la croissance
maximale concerne le groupe de personnes
entre 20 et 39 ans la partie la plus
active de la population
je voudrais aussi attirer votre
attention sur le fait que le nombre de
cas sans symptôme a également doublé ce
qui nous rappelle la nécessité de
respecter toutes les précautions et le
de 21 millions de russes ont déjà reçu
la première dose du vaccin dont plus de
2 millions à moscou selon le ministre de
la santé michael mot âge qu avec quatre
vaccins disponibles différents pour la
population les autorités de la capitale
espère largement augmenter le nombre de
personnes vaccinées
et comme disent les médecins toute
pandémie fini avec la vaccination